history is in fact the democratic
election lies with them oh truth doesn't
seem to matter and they showed that true
colors after 2016. here's more from the
Montage that Marco Rubio posted on
Twitter take a look
U.S election hacking the U.S election
Russia hacked our elections the Russians
hacked our election Russia hacked our
election Russia hacked our election
hacking of our elections hacking of our
of our elections Russia hacked our
elections the universal assessment that
Russia hacked our elections we will see
how illegitimate his victory actually
was he's an illegitimate president
Russia hacked our elections questions
hacking our election hacked our election
Russia hacking our elections president
as a legitimate president four million
people have already signed a petition on
change.org calling for the electors of
the Electoral College to quote ignore
their states votes and casts their
ballots for secretary Clinton let's
bring in Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett former action Attorney General
did uh did Russia hack our election was
the trump-russia collusion true
because I read the Durham report and
said no no I wrote two books
way back in 2018 was the first one and I
said it was all a hoax that the dossier
was phony you know Americans lived not
just through Hillary Clinton getting
away with crimes in her email Scandal
but they watched as Hillary Clinton
invented the Russia hoax Finance the
phony dossier James Comey and others at
the FBI lie to the American public to
Congress to the fisa court and they all
got away with it and they tried to drive
Trump from office with a hoax and now
they see the same sort of thing
unfolding unscrupulous unprincipled
prosecutors whose sole goal is not the
merits of the case they're bringing but
they hope to gain a conviction or to
smear and Sully Trump sufficiently to
enable Joe Biden to win the Mantra is
Biden can't win legitimately on his own
so we will help him by hook or by Crook
and that's what's behind these four
indictments you agree with that Matt
Whitaker
yeah yeah I do and remember they've now
scheduled this first uh trial on the day
before super Tuesday where 15 states
plus American Samoa are going to go vote
and and if you're thinking you can
prepare for a trial and visit 15 states
uh in the lead up to Super Tuesday I
mean that's going to be impossible so
obviously what Greg's saying is
absolutely right this is all planned and
coordinated in order to try to prevent
Donald Trump uh from being strong enough
to win the election in November but
knowing the guy like I do I don't think
they're going to stop him
what I mean I I you agree with me I
don't think you can get a fair trial in
New York City or in DC or Fulton County
yeah but they they're counting on the
fact these prosecutors that he won't get
a fair trial and that he'll be convicted
and they realize fully that they will
likely be overturned in the courts
before the election care about getting
overturned later they care about
stopping Trump now to help Joe Biden so
that means timeline wise that the trial
will be held in the election year and
the appeal will be after the election
yeah but uh
Fannie Willis down in Fulton County
Georgia you know is scuppered by her own
schemes because she was dumb enough to
charge
161 conspiratorial acts 41 criminal
charges 19 defendants it is impossible
to try them all together with let's say
there's two lawyers per defendant you're
talking about 60 people just litigating
the case complex issues she's over
complicated you know a smart prosecutor
streamlines the case just a handful of
charges one defendant but no Fanny
Willis ain't smart and she's been
hoisted by her own patard in this case
all right Craig Jarrett Matt Whitaker
thank you both we appreciate it all
right